elle l'aide alimentaire européenne à
nouveau menacé le 23 octobre sera
présenté un nouveau programme social par
la commission européenne et les
organisations d'aidé alimentaire sont
inquiètes banque alimentaire restos du
coeur croix rouge et secours populaire
veulent mobiliser bonsoir pascal rodier
vous êtes le secrétaire général du
secours populaire dans le département
des yvelines on va donc parler de ce
plan daide européen plan d aide
alimentaire pour bien situer repréciser
ces 500 millions d'euros annuels qui
permettent de distribuer des repas à 18
millions de personnes
il était créée en 1987 il y a deux ans à
peu près il avait déjà été remis en
cause un plaisir là plusieurs pays
européens avaient critiqué les modalités
d'attribution le type de fonctionnement
aujourd'hui on arrive au bout des deux
ans de sursis qui avaient été posées et
vous êtes inquiet vous pensez que cette
aide va disparaître en tout cas le
nouveau système qui sera mis en place ne
sera pas suffisant pour aider les
populations qui viennent vous voir
notamment
bah disons qu'il ya une incertitude déjà
sur la possibilité d'une continuation
puisque effectivement il est prévu que
fin 2013 mais ça c'était le premier rhum
de négociation prévoyait fin 2013 de
toute façon le système évoluerait et la
mouture qui est en train de se préparer
pour l'instant au niveau de la
commission européenne pour que ce soit
proposé au parlement et au conseil
européen des ministres suppose que c'est
un peu technique mais c'est un processus
comme ça de décision au niveau européen
la formule qui est à l'étude pour
l'instant
se traduirait par un engagement sur 7 en
mai sur une diminution d'à peu près 140
millions d'euros annuels sachant que il
manquait déjà par rapport à ce que les
états membres
faisait connaître comme besoin il
manquait déjà 100 millions ce plan daide
européens profitent à 18 millions de
personnes dans 20 pays de l'union
européenne parmi les principaux
bénéficiaires la pologne l'italie
également la france parmi les pays qui
critiquait le système tel qu'il existait
en tout cas qu'il existe jusqu'à encore
lié pour encore quelques mois on
retrouve et l'allemagne la noyer qui ne
comprenaient pas puisqu'au début août
être ré expliquer même si effectivement
ces techniques c'étaient les surplus de
la politique commune agricole qui
étaient redistribuées finalement il n'y
avait plus de surplus donc ce sont les
états qui se substituait qui versaient
de l'argent et ça ne plaît pas à
l'allemagne c'est sale alors le blocage
se fait au niveau de l'allemagne
il ya une minorité de blocage qui tourne
effectivement autour de l'allemagne mais
plus que l'impossibilité d'une enveloppe
financière a débloqué
même si ça peut être un argument
toujours avancer en temps de crise c'est
plutôt une approche en fait juridique de
ce que l'on veut faire de l'europe c'est
à dire qu' il ya des pays qui disent
qu'il faut faire une europe sociale avec
des fonds qui sont alloués à ça et puis
il ya une autre vision qui est tenue en
règle générale par les pays anglo saxons
et les allemands devant aussi parce que
c'est une fédération de landes
l'allemagne et donc qu'elle a une
histoire l'allemagne a une histoire
particulière c'est à dire que voilà
c'est une fédération de c'est une
fédération des landes et sont donc
autorisés à la même conception à la paix
ils ont un principe ce qu'on appelle de
subsidiarité
ils disent qu'en fait ça c'est du rôle
des états nations qui délègue
éventuellement à leurs structures
régionales c'est pas du rôle de d'une
instance au dessus des états et puis il
ya d'autres pays qui pensent que non
l'union européenne n'est pas qu'un
marché
avec liberté de circulation de capitaux
il ya aussi quand même des gens dedans
éventuellement il ya peut-être moyen de
faire un peu de social dans l'histoire
est que en fait ça vienne apporter une
valeur ajoutée à ce qui se fait par les
états membres et donc venus la devise
loading actuellement avec les autres
organismes on va appeler ça comme ça il
ya une opération c'est comme si on
lançait erfoud le m food mais voilà ça
peut paraître comme quelque chose à la
mode mais non c'est tout à fait sérieux
l'idée c'est effectivement de de
sensibiliser aux conséquences concrètes
de l'arrêt de cette aide alimentaire les
gens n'auront plus de quoi se nourrir
alors vous avez lancé le erfoud ça
consiste en quoi
alors en fait c'est une agence qui
travaille pour nos quatre associations
et donc qui vise à sensibiliser
largement grand public et ça s'appelle
the heures de fou er food project points
comme et l'idée et demi mais en fait
ce qui se passera pour 18 millions
d'européens s'il ya plus de programme
européen d'aidé aux démunis c'est à dire
qu'il y aura plus à manger
on va donc effectivement le voilà et le
grand public est invité en fait faire
des petits films et à les mettre en
contributions sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur le site qui s'appelle donc erfoud
project points comme de manière à
sensibiliser très largement et pour les
accros des réseaux sociaux il ya même
les comptes twitter des principaux
décideurs européens et de madame angela
merkel pour lui dire coucou
ce serait bien d'avoir dépensé un peu
positif pour programme européen d'aidé
aux démunis
donc les organismes sont à la page on va
dire aussi puisque vous savez
communiquer sur les nouveaux réseaux
sociaux vous avez vu quelques images on
vous renvoie vers ce site foot project
nous sommes allés en tout de même vous
poser la question si vous aviez déjà
entendu parler de ce concept de erfoud
lancé pour sensibiliser autour de ce
programme dead européen alimentaire
menacée actuellement qui va être refondu
dans les prochains mois vous restez avec
nous sur plateau juste après on va
parler d'une autre actions que vous
menez spécifique avec l'organisme du
département des yvelines
erfoud erfoud et ra hier il ya de l'air
dedans et fourrées crc les nourritures
gonfler avec dit oui oui je crois que ou
alors soit on part de molécules et
wallers et la nourriture - müller ça
doit être quelque chose comme ça pied c
gepa du football sans ballon je dirais
ça c'est un anglicisme et c'est ça c'est
manger dans la rue je dirais que c'est
des gens qui te films sur internet et
qui mettent ça sur internet et qui mange
du vent
de façon à être solidaires avec les gens
qui ont faim ces cars food
si vous voulez vous c'est carrefour le
erfoud c'est très sérieux pour venir en
aide aux organismes d aide alimentaire
pascal rodier secrétaire général du
secours populaire donc dans les yvelines
vous êtes aussi sur le plateau ce soir
pour nous parler de sept autres actions
que vous menez avec action mopti
justement sur le département un
programme d aide au mali un programme
des dents en trois volets alimentaire
sanitaire et scolaire
alors c'est pas avec akio petit c'est
avec une association que connaît action
mopti à ce que l'action au petit c'est
une association qui existe depuis très
très longtemps sûrement pas et on a des
amis bénévoles du secours populaire qui
sont aussi actifs dans cette association
mis en relation donc voilà c'est précis
ça fait deux ans qu'on fait des
programmes qu'on m'appelle activités
génératrices de revenus avec une
association locale et je pense que tout
le monde a entendu parler de la
situation dramatique que connaît le nord
mali avec la montée des intégrismes là
le bouclage de la zone du nord et donc
les migrations très importante de deux
populations qui fuient
les situations d'insécurité et donc nous
au niveau de la fédération comme on a
des correspondants locaux on est en
capacité de faire un petit programme
comme vous avez dit sur trois volets un
peu de secours alimentaire de du
sanitaire et du scolaire pour
prioritairement pour les enfants qui qui
ont été obligés de partir de chez eux et
qu'ils sont accueillis dans les familles
d'accueil ou dans des connaissances et
donc comme il se trouve que le pays est
comme toute la bande sahélienne aussi
malheureusement connu sur la dernière
saison pluie enfin pas la dernière mais
celle d'avant
des précipitations catastrophique et en
plus une situation de tension
alimentaire existantes
en plus de la situation politique vous
avez des bouquets de 3000 euros c'est
sam jusqu'à présent il pas suffisant
pour mettre à bas les mettre en place
non c'est de l'ordre du symbolique
franchement c'est de l'ordre du
symbolique alors les symboles
ne sont pas des symboles pour les gens
qui bénéficient de l'aide c'est à dire
que si vous proposez à 20 familles un
secours alimentaire d'urgence une
famille étant composé d'environ une
dizaine de personnes ça fait pas ça fait
pas rien mais
le faudrait dit pas ce que vous appeler
aux dons les affiches votre site
internet on peut s'y référer pour faire
des dons secours populaire des yvelines
pour tout vous dire notre partenaire au
début nous a fait une première
proposition d'intervention à 200000
euros
donc effectivement c'est dans l'ordre du
symbolique avec ses réserves et ploguer
c'est pas du tout dans nos capacités
d'intervention habituel et nous ne
sommes pas nous ne nous qualifions pas
comme une association urgentistes sommes
une association de solidarité avant tout
donc on intervient dans le cadre de la
solidarité mais on peut aisément doubler
tripler ou quadrupler la possibilité
d'intervention si jamais on réussi à
collecter les fonds justement vous
collectez les fonds auscitaine ou
peut-être un exemple concret d'action
vous allez pouvoir mener si vous
réunissez réussissait à réunir à ac2
dont les biens ont évoqué les trois axes
c'est vrai que le financement sur le
volet sanitaire
ben ça va permettre d'assurer une prise
en charge des enfants qui sont touchés
par le palu pour le niveau scolaire
c'est l'équipe d'accès à l'école y
compris avec la réalisation de
l'uniforme puisque dans beaucoup de pays
sasson ça fonctionne comme ça il y en
uniforme et puis une dotation un sac les
premières fournitures scolaires donc ce
premier travail aidés a déjà été opéré
on a même fait des économies d'échelle
niveau local et on a pu aider deux fois
plus que ce qu'on avait prévu donc et
puis après les dotations alimentaire
c'est les produits de base farine huile
sucre
et donc l'idée on sent peut faire des
dons directement voilà alors si on fait
des dons au niveau de la fédération
on va pouvoir après par tranche de
programmes rajouter des personnes
bénéficiaires merci d'être venu nous
parler de cette opération on suivra on
verra comment les choses évoluent
n'hésitait pas à nous solliciter pour
qu'on puisse relayer cette information
d'appel aux dons
n'hésitez pas à contacter le secours
populaire via notamment son site
internet et puisque nous parlons de
sociétés des questions sociales sachez
également que demain 17 octobre ce sera
la journée internationale du refus de la
misère atd quart monde en france plus de
8,6 millions de personnes vivent sous le
seuil de promo pauvreté c'est à dire
avec moins de 964 euros des rendez-vous
auront lieu à paris au trocadéro aussi
dans les yvelines à saint germain en
laye et dès ce soir le 16 octobre soirée
débat à 20h30 à la mairie de
louveciennes sur le thème combat contre
la misère et défense de la dignité le
7-8 touche presque à sa fin
nous allons juste nous parler de
politique très rapidement olivier
delaporte le maire de la celle saint
cloud et conseiller général veut
réintégrer l'ump exclu de l'ump pour
avoir maintenu sa candidature face à
henri guaino dans la troisième
circonscription lors des législatives il
a adressé un courrier au secrétaire
général du mouvement jean françois copé
expliquant notamment que la campagne
était restée sereine et qu'à l'issue du
premier tour il avait retiré sa
candidature au profit d' henri guaino
arrivés en tête
pas de réponse encore à ce jour pour
donc le maire de la celle saint cloud
mais il se dit que son soutien affiché à
françois fillon dans la course à la
présidence de l'ump expliqueraient ce
choix de jean françois copé
de son côté valérie pécresse la chef de
file de l'ump que nous avons contacté
cet après midi et nous a indiqué qu'elle
souhaitait que olivier delaporte soit
réintégré au nom de l'unité de sa
famille politique voilà pour ces
quelques précisions c'est la fin de
cette édition du 7 8 de ce 16 octobre
prochaine diffusion 19h 22h30 et minuit
le 7-8 demain mercredi en direct à
partir de 18h excellente soirée